so the round is over David Cameron's
resignation on assist yesterday for
Sunday Times published an apparent leak
of the list it showed honors being
showered on donors to remain campaigns
such as in a tailor of your old company
be Top members of David Cameron's stop
including salmon Samantha Cameron's
executive assistant Isabel spearmen and
those who work for the in campaign
including will straw who ran it critics
are saying that these are a slap in the
face for the electorate because the
electorate both for beretta they are
also saying that these are rewards to
fade it because it in campaign
ultimately failed in its attempt to get
Britain to stay in the European Union
now traditionally prime ministers have
given out honors as they've left Downing
Street obtains reward those who worked
very hard for them over long periods of
time but this practice had fallen into
abeyance the last prime ministers do it
was John Major now there's a lot in a
big rabbits but the question is what
happens next while Jane Street have been
clear this morning victories main won't
seek to interfere list she won't try to
prune it down or veto any of your names
on it I think that's the right decision
because whether you agree with the list
or not it should be David Cameron's call
on whether it's on at all but the thing
that the country needs to work out is
whether it wants to have a system which
allows prime ministers to hand out
honors as they leave office or not